une minute d'applaudissements puis le
temps des larmes hommage plein d'émotion
ce dimanche à avignon pour saluer la
mémoire d'éric masson brigadier tué
mercredi lors d'une interpellation à 1
points de deal un nouvel épisode
tragique un nouveau choc et une colère
que les forces de l'ordre ont de plus en
plus de mal à contenir cette violence
mais évidemment doigts si c'est
l'endroit des forces de l'ordre dans
l'endroit des gardiens de la paix ce
n'est pas normal d'accepter de tolérer
cette violence là elle était non vous
savez dans nos rangs tous les ans vous
avez dix mille policiers sont blessés un
service et 10000 policiers blessés par
an et services demain chez 1er mai il
faudra qu'ils légifèrent
il faudra qu'ils lancent un signal fort
et une réponse pénale adaptée à la
situation
interpellé jean castex doit recevoir les
syndicats de police lundi en visite dans
un commissariat de cergy le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin à lui
réaffirmé sa volonté de lutter contre le
trafic en bande organisée cette lutte
contre les trafics de stupéfiants qui
est la mère de toutes les batailles
parce que les trafics de stupéfiants ça
fait naître les cambriolages
ça fait naître les tentatives d'homicide
ça fait naître les agressions ça fait
naître les accidents de la route
ça fait naître le financement du
terrorisme 7 août contre les stupéfiants
elle est essentielle pour sauver le plus
enfants de la république de cette merde
qu'est la langue mais ses nombreuses
batailles les forces de l'ordre ont
parfois l'impression de les mener seul
guet-apens à rillieux-la-pape tirs de
mortiers à fréjus agression au tournevis
à villeurbanne ces derniers jours les
violences envers les policiers se sont
multipliées vendredi jean castex affirmé
vouloir améliorer la réponse pénale et
généraliser les caméras de surveillance
le premier ministre a aussi promis de
débloquer 10 millions d'euros pour
sécuriser les commissariats
mardi il doit présider une cérémonie
d'hommage à éric masson en compagnie de
gérald darmanin
pour saluer la mémoire de leur collègue
les syndicats de police eux ont appelé à
une marche citoyenne le 19 mai à paris